you're full of [__] estrogen dude
really
you know what you're gonna love this not
at all so you're dating a girl
oh my God I know did he transition the
vet well you know what's weird the vet
transition I think I might be a trans
man
oh goodness gracious like how would you
know if you were a trans man listen if
you want to be back in Hollywood there
are other ways to go
upstairs there's there's other ways not
like super I mean you've seen me you've
seen me date a lot of men that are way
more feminine than any woman I've had in
order I like the last guy you were
dating
masculine energy in La I will say this
and I thought that you were dating like
a veteran yeah and then I saw him and
then I was like oh it's the other vet
but it was still like a nice guy I would
find a guy that had his legs blown off
so he couldn't run away yeah that sounds
like something she would do I could see
you doing that I could see the only way
to get a man that has guns in this
country can you imagine I mean there are
other places do you have a gun guys are
like no and I'm like I just can't I
don't know I know it's like a problem in
America but leave a gun uh I have one in
my house it's not loaded though
I would have so you have a problem
it's like like if someone if you have a
problem in your house I get so when I
dye my hair [__] blue I got all these
guys that I guess there's some anime
video game where there's a girl with
blue hair and then all these anime dorks
they put on headsets and they thought we
were married or in a simulation together
or something so a lot of doors would
start showing up in my house because my
[__] was on Reddit or whatever and so
um uh you know laf the LAPD I mean the
whole thing is like you don't really
need like you're not a BB gun I have
loaded but if you have a gun like that
solves half you're having four different
conversations with yourself right now
first of all how dare you I came in here
I'm being attacked by you [__]
I can't get anyone to molest me anymore
we're going on to like movie sets TV
sets we went to women
yeah I mean it's like my mom
died thing and now we gotta feel bad but
I don't why you did that I feel great
about it don't do that she was a baby
she was a it would not didn't love me
much
yeah she put me into like modeling when
I was a teenager like I look back at
pictures these are beautiful and just
you know
Rogan and I were talking about this to
be honest with you about how stunning
everything because we have such a
platonic relationship every now and then
like one of my guy friends will be like
tell us about it like well no like
you're like pretty and I'm like
it's just like grief does wild [__] you
know what I mean well this kind of
proves the theory I've always had about
you which is you just want company
interesting to a company to run a
company
you just want company you just want
something around like you know what I
mean and it's just like something that
kind of fits your schedule it fits your
lifestyle fits everything but you don't
want to be completely you know dependent
on that person it's just going to be
different out and there's a couple
things also I just went off birth
control I was on birth control for 20
years you're 63 years old what do you
mean
I've been on birth control so what birth
control does is uh it makes your body
think you're pregnant so number one you
keep on weight so now I think that's
part of the reason you got shredded and
it makes you like hyper Vigilant like
paranoid you smell pheromones
differently so you're attracted to a
different kind of man like they always
say before you marry someone you should
make sure they go off birth control for
at least a year before you like get
married to make sure you're still it's
just progesterone right um
they're all kind of different the one
that I had was the Moraine IUD because I
had such bad migraines but like I didn't
realize like because when you're
pregnant think about it it makes sense
you would biologically want to be
attracted to someone that's more of a
risk taker someone that would be sort of
more
um of a protector so it's like I was
[__] with guys with like lessons no
no you would want for the father of your
child maybe but you would want someone
that would be able to protect your child
yeah but risk Shaker he could die and
then I gotta raise it yeah but someone
that can like also fight for your kid
who's you know that kind of thing and
then I was like just attracted to such
more like extreme like intense people
like addicts like motorcycles
veterinarians that that when did you get
on
don't do that don't you dare do that
it's not a rock climber in the 1700s
showing on it did I need to know what's
going on you come on here you say you're
a big old bull Dyke out of nowhere
come on
what did Emma take down your Die Hard
poster what's going on
you coming
in you're lying about something you sure
are you such a grump yes how
I have some rage at me Andrew this is a
new kind of race this is a good
defensive strategy you come in here you
accuse it this is gaslighting this is
gaslighting do you learn this from your
lesbians yes she's been dating women now
she knows how they know how to do it you
come in here I've always been around
dating women yeah yeah this is the first
time I've actually dated a woman it's
actually just like a little more like
helpful you know what I'm saying like
you get God
more women are being admitted to
universities these days